today I want to redefine an element of
leadership to you
you know too often when we think about
leader we think about somebody who is
making a difference doing great things
and going out there and winning and all
this that that's a person that's a
leader but I want you to know one of the
skill sets you gotta learn in life is
you need to know the difference between
different kind of leaders in the world
because I think on one hand the one
thing that we always think about as a
leader the person that went to war and
save people's lives and encouraged them
to dream and Martin Luther King says I
have a dream you oughta dream as well
Lincoln won and changed the world you
know a patent or a Churchill or Reagan
or Kennedy they inspire they inject they
get people who want to move they get
people who want to go out there and do
something very big with their lives
inspiration they fire you up they get
you to do something you would have never
done by yourself right that's a leader
that we think about when we portray
somebody in or minds who's a leader
that's who leaders but I want you to
think about the other leader and I want
you to go back okay to junior high
school or high school I want you to
think about the kid whoever this kid was
that offered you a cigarette for the
very first time or drugs or alcohol or
wanted you to do something that you knew
probably wasn't the best thing for you
to do do you remember that kid everybody
has one kid right so you may say well I
don't take the action it doesn't matter
what matter whether you did or it didn't
what matters the most is how many people
do you remember took action based on
what that person offers other people to
do right if more than a handful of
people did something that wasn't good
for them guess what that kid is also
leader that kid is absolutely also
leader why first let's define leadership
the dictionary tells us leadership means
the action of leading a group of people
or organization period if that kid led a
handful of kids to try cigarettes
alcohol or drugs he was the leader of
that group so now wait a minute are we
saying leadership could be positive or
negative
absolutely the challenge we're going to
have in our lives is how do we tell the
two apart
right
gonna come across the leader that's
gonna tell you can do it you should go
for it
I think can pull this off it's gonna be
painful but you should give it a shot
what if it does take points what if you
go out there make a difference what if
you do live your dreams what if you go
against all the odds what if you prove
everybody wrong in your life that said
you can do it there are leaders like
that in your life right and they're
gonna tell you it's gonna be very hard
it's gonna be difficult at times it's
gonna be lonely at times right so this
is a tougher advise to take at times by
the way a lot fewer leaders like this in
the world but there's gonna be tens of
thousands of people on this site that
will lead you in safe you know you can't
do it you know all those kids all they
care about is money you know they talk
about is their cars and their houses and
all this stuff and you know what
let me tell you about what they do and
let me tell you buy this and they spread
rumors and they gossip and they get into
your mind and it's like a flu or a virus
that it gets into you we never know how
we got our fruit we never know how we
got our cold it could mean a person's
hand you shook that one like this before
you shook their hands in a you want like
this you caught a call it's the same
exact way how somebody don't like this
becomes negative and quits on their
dream you can't trace it back and say it
was this person it happened so suddenly
that when it comes to your food they
influence your decision-making process
in a decision you make could absolutely
affect the rest of your life so what do
we do about this coupon what do we do
about this group regardless of how good
you and I are it doesn't matter we're
all at one point gonna fall for the
group here that's gonna fool us and lead
us into doing something that's not the
best for us but eventually after a lot
of mistakes we come to a point that the
gift of intuition where you got two
people giving you advice in your ear
once telling you should go for it's
gonna be tough and all this I've give it
a shot another person is gonna say give
me a break you don't believe all this
stuff they tell you they're just that
that that's that all the stuff they feed
your mind all the rumors all the
negativity this is so much easier to
believe this is so much easier to sell
believe me this is so much easier to buy
i I am so flabbergasted by how naive
some people are when they fall for every
single little room
every single little ruler and this
reminds me of one of my favorite quotes
by Churchill he once said a lie gets
halfway around the world before the
truth has a chance to get his pants on
why because we have such an easier time
buying rumors and gossip and buying it
to someone's victim with mentality than
we do a leader who's challenged you to
change to improve and go out and do
something big in your life it'll be on
you to tell the tool part it's my
message of the week to you I'm please be
sure to subscribe and share this video